hey whats up guys it was Marcus brown
lahir from mkbhd and welcome to another
HD tutorial and this tutorial is going
to be a piece of freeware that i found
that will convert any video file or any
media video file to be imported into
itunes and put directly onto your ipod
so here's how you do that first of all
i'm going to put this link in the
description is another dvdvideosoft com
piece of freeware and other favors just
updated once you click on it you'll be
able to download this particular piece
of freeware that I'm showing you and
once you finish downloading and
installing it you will come up with this
free studio manager right here and in
order to download the video to excuse me
video to ipod converter just go ahead
and click it and it will open up or
begin the download and installation
process without you having to do much
work so it's going to go ahead and go to
the direct link and hit the download now
button and in a second here we go we can
go ahead and hit that run button and the
download will start up and we'll be on
our way to installing the free video to
ipod converter so i'm going to exit out
of the internet browser in the
background here and exit out of the in
the studio so i'm actually going to come
back to you guys once this is done if it
takes a little while to open up we'll
see how long this one takes and actually
it's already almost done so we go ahead
and hit that run button here because we
do in fact trust this DXE file and
should um should your windows just a
prompt come up you know saying do you
want to allow the software do you want
to deny it obviously you hit allow for
everything hit the next button hit the
next button and i'm just going to
disable these two hit next and install
and now the installation should go
pretty quickly it's a pretty small piece
of freeware but it's very simple and
very powerful one at that so once this
is done installing your free video to
ipod converter is ready to run so we're
going to go ahead and go open up that
free studio again that we downloaded in
the first place
so let's just go ahead and exit safari
and go ahead and open up that studio
here's the studio and you'll see that
option that was great out before number
14 is now a darker and you cannot click
on it so this is the free video to ipod
and PSP converter converter yes this
work for PS PS and here you go so first
thing you're going to choose is your
input file this can be a QuickTime movie
and am I and avi at WMV any any media
file that is in fact video that you want
to put on your iPod so I'm just going to
go ahead take a random WMV file WMV
files usually are not able to be put on
two iPods and you can always trim this
if you want you can cut down cut it down
to 13 14 seconds it's your little a
little video editor here this is my old
introduction video so once you have
you've selected the file you want to put
on your iPod or your device actually
you're going to go ahead and select an
output folder so i'll say final for the
output name and your output folder i'm
just going to go ahead and put it on my
desktop and then you're going to select
your device you can select an ipod and
iphone your Apple TV your PSP or your
mobile phone that supports mp4 so let's
just go ahead and say we're going to put
this on our iPhone will click iphone it
alot select our iphone preset you can
select iphone high quality standard or
economic i'm going to go ahead and put
it on high quality and hit that convert
button and there we go it is going to
begin to convert that file and it's
going to put it on our desktop like we
said and it doesn't actually take that
long if it is a larger file it'll take a
little bit longer but the conversion has
already been completed successfully so
i'll go ahead and close it exit it out
and here we have the final intro video
the mpeg-4 that will work on the ipod
that used to be a WMV and that we can
now put on our iphone so i hope you guys
enjoyed this free tutorial this is a
little piece of software about how to
take any media file or any video file
and put it on your iPod or PSP I hope
this helped and if you have any other
questions or tutorial ideas or requests
feel free to subscribe to
send me a message through youtube I do
read all of my messages and I you might
get a request video done for you so
thanks for watching this video guys
peace